My guest is penny white.
Professor at the University of Tennessee College of law.
Uh,
justice wider was justice wide on the Tennessee Supreme Court.
Started out in Johnson City,
Tennessee,
which is where she grew up.
I was elected to the trial court there and presided over,
uh,
all kinds of cases,
criminal and civil as a trial judge.
But in a very short time,
she was appointed by the governor of Tennessee to the intermediate appellate
court.
Uh,
that's the court between the trial court and the Tennessee Supreme Court.
She served there and then was appointed to the Tennessee Supreme Court.
Uh,
she was about to become the first,
uh,
woman chief justice in the history of Tennessee,
when there was a campaign,
uh,
to,
prevent her retention on the ballot as a justice of the,
of the court.
And we've asked justice white professor white to come and talk with us about,
uh,
issues of judicial independence.
Uh,
and maybe just tell us a little bit about what happened,
uh,
when you thought you were on the ballot,
didn't anticipate any problems and what happened?
Well the best way to describe it as a perfect storm,
I found myself as the loan candidate on the ballot.
That's because I was serving an unexpired term.
So that's the way it works in Tennessee.
So an easy target.
Um,
the campaign against me began six weeks to the day of the retention race.
So an unexpected,
uh,
development,
which we weren't prepared to,
um,
to counter.
And the,
the surrogate,
the what,
what the opponents used was a capital case,
a case in which air court had remanded for a new sentencing based on a really
fundamental evidence ruling that was incorrect as well as a,
uh,
an interpretation of state law.
We had remanded that capital case for new sentencing.
And that case was used by my opposition to paint me as a soft on crime anti
death penalty judge and to convince the voters really that the only way to have
capital punishment in Tennessee would be to remove me from the bench.
Um,
ironically it was the first capital case as an appellate judge that I had ever
sat on at that level.
Uh,
so,
so really the,
the caricature that they painted of me was a false one,
but it certainly was one that stuck.
Now when you sue is in Christ,
you meant the trial judge's ruling was incorrect and that's why the court,
one of the two reasons the court set aside,
right?
The,
the trial judge's ruling was incorrect on an evidence matter.
Basically just,
just letting,
um,
in a capital case,
of course the jury has the right to know the good and the bad about a person
whose life is in their hands.
And in this particular case,
the judge had excluded,
uh,
about some of the mitigating circumstances.
And so that was one of the reasons for saying,
for our court saying that the case needed to go back for a new sentencing wasn't
that the court was setting aside the death sentence.
It was just that the court was telling the trial,
judge,
you made a mistake.
Now let's try this case fairly.
But rather than portray the case in that light,
the opposition and those who wanted to remove me from the bench portrayed it as
if it were a stance against capital punishment per se in Tennessee had had not
executed.
Many people at that time had not executed anyone really since forming versus
Georgia came down for the United States Supreme Court.
And so people were a little antsy.
We had almost a hundred inmates on death row and there was a contingency of
individuals who wanted to see,
uh,
the death penalty working more quickly.
Uh,
and so it was an,
an easy,
a emotional issue for those who wanted to remove me from the bench to latch
onto.
Uh,
it,
it plays not only in my case,
but in other cases where we've seen judges around the country,
it plays on people's fear,
on their anxiety,
and it's very hard to stand up and,
uh,
run against that kind of rhetoric,
because if you say that you intend to be fair,
uh,
very often that is misread or misheard as being soft on crime.
And once,
once you get labeled with a soft on crime label,
it is very hard,
uh,
to get rid of it.
And case in point in,
in my situation I had decided hundreds of appellate decisions and if you looked
at them and can kind of categorize them into which ones I had sided with the
defendant and which ones I had sided with the,
with the prosecution,
the overwhelming number way over three quarters,
approximately 85% of the time I had agreed with the state yet this one case,
uh,
was,
was what was used to paint me as the,
as the soft on crime judge.
And it's such an actually she didn't reverse the conviction.
Exactly.
No,
the conviction stood and the only thing that the court did was remand the case
for a new Senate saying the capitol proceeding being a bifurcated or two step
process.
Uh,
so we only reversed it four or remanded it rather for,
for a re sentencing.
Um,
the individual was against sentence to death.
And,
uh,
again,
ironically the case went back up on appeal several years after I had left the
bench.
The court reversed it again and this time without any publicity or public outcry
at all,
which just further confirms that the case was basically just being used to
manipulate the public in that election.
Now since the time you've taught,
you continue to
teach with the judicial college,
you teach judges and Tennessee and you've also talked a lot about judicial
independence.
Do you see this sort of thing going on,
uh,
in other parts of the country and another judicial races?
Unfortunately it is,
it is all too common.
Um,
and I think what is really important to communicate is that while crime may be
the,
um,
the story or the topic that is used to attack a judicial candidate,
it is rarely what the opposition is really interested in.
Most often these,
these types of campaigns are waged by big dollar interest,
um,
sometimes by insurance companies,
sometimes by special interest groups that have agendas related to family law
issues.
But those issues are harder to ignite and fuel and anger and scare the
electorate with.
So crime is used as as the surrogate and often a judge,
any judge,
any appellate judge who's,
who's done her job will have reversed cases.
Judges,
trial judges make mistakes,
prosecutors make mistakes.
The law changes.
And the appellate courts are there for that very purpose to make sure that that
errors are corrected.
So any judge who sat on the bench for anytime at all,
we'll have had a case or two or 10 or 20 in which they have fighted with the
accused.
And so it's very easy to pluck those individual cases and,
and really magnify them and make them,
make them look like they are the whole of the judge's record.
And once a judge gets attacked on an issue like that,
trying to respond,
it puts you on the defensive,
makes you look like you're making excuses or trying to distance yourself from
the decisions,
but you aren't.
You're simply trying to get the public to look at your entire record.
So it's,
it's so,
so to be more direct to your question,
yes,
it's happening all too.
All too frequently and it's often happening in just the way it happened.
In my case only with millions and millions of dollars now,
which was not something that,
that I had to contend with.
Judges today are finding themselves having to work while they're on the bench to
stay on the bitch at the next election,
building up a war chest,
building up support,
which obviously is taking their attention away from their duties.
Uh,
and so it,
it is,
uh,
a serious threat to the independence of the judiciary into the separateness of
the judicial branch of government.
And how does it affect the judges who remain on the bench?
The cases that have people voted off are usually criminal cases.
So the courts sitting on a controversial criminal case.
Yeah.
Huh.
Well,
I mean,
I think just just from a point of view of,
of practicality,
even given the judge a judge with the utmost integrity,
uh,
judge who's trying her best to be ethical and to follow the rule of law,
there is that nagging,
nagging thought in the back of her head that what will happen if I decide the
case in this way?
I don't want to be heard to say that.
I think all judges compromise themselves in that way.
I don't,
I think many struggle daily,
not too.
And I think the best judges are those who take the bench and say,
I'm going to rule correctly every day that I'm here and if I'm removed for rule
incorrectly,
so be it.
But,
but when a judge takes the bench in this and gives up a law practice,
gives up a lucrative career,
has family,
uh,
and,
and wants to build a pension,
wants to build a retirement and,
uh,
you know,
tenure on the court,
that idea of deciding cases consistent with the public will and not inconsistent
with some special interest groups agenda,
uh,
can,
can definitely influence decision making.
And very often these like,
oh,
let's take the,
not too long ago,
uh,
just justice,
Kilbride was on the ballot in Illinois,
again,
like your election,
it was a retention election.
That election was really about a vote he had made in a case about punitive
damages are limits on damages.
Uh,
but the campaign was mostly about,
uh,
criminal cases that he had set up.
Right.
And,
and in,
in a couple of,
of of observations about that race as well.
You mentioned that it was a retention race where the voters simply have to vote
yes or no.
And in the past,
uh,
not,
not the distant past.
In the early two thousands and certainly in the 1990s when we talked about money
in judicial campaigns,
we generally we're talking about money being spent in states that had partisan
judicial elections so that the political parties would be involved in racing and
great deal of money lawyers and business interests would raise a great deal of
money.
But what we've seen is that this money is now infiltrating not only partisan
judicial races where it might be somewhat more expected,
but also nonpartisan judicial races and retention races.
And when you're running a retention race,
you're running against nobody.
So the only thing the opposition has to do is put a black mark on you and then
the public really when they vote,
no,
they're,
they're not.
There's not a way to compare your credentials or your experience or your
background with another candidate.
You're running against this great idea that whoever takes the bench after you
won't have whatever the fault is that the opposition has tried to suggest you
have.
So,
so it's a harder rice to,
to run really,
uh,
even though you only have to get yes votes.
Uh,
additionally on the justice Kilbride situations,
I mean,
thankfully he was able to,
to win his election with millions,
literally more than more than $2 million spent.
But,
but the public believed that they were voting on that they were led to believe
by the commercials that they were voting based upon his record on criminal
cases.
As you suggested,
the,
the advertisements,
which I think maybe in maybe in the material,
certainly people can find those advertisements are,
are,
are scary,
are threatening and frightening and,
and really,
um,
it's tasteless,
just really tasteless.
But the real reason that the money was spent against justice Kilbride was
because insurance companies disagreed with a ruling that he made in a tort case.
And very often tort cases,
limits on damages are the issues that bring out the money.
And most of the ways that public gets their information about judges when
they're up for his 32nd
yeah,
there are states that are doing a lot to,
to do better than that,
but the public has to put forth a little bit of effort.
For example,
a number of states do have voter guides.
A number of states have what are called judicial performance evaluation systems
where judges who were on the bench are evaluated based upon criteria that is
essential to judging,
not based upon political stances or philosophies.
And so these,
um,
evaluations are then produced in voter guides,
uh,
of different,
of different lengths and different types.
And in some states they're available on a website for the state judicial branch.
In other states,
I will ask her,
for example,
they're mailed to every household.
So if the public will go to the internet or receives one of these voter guides
and we'll take the time to,
to read.
In some of those states,
there is more information available.
But what studies tell us is that,
you know,
the,
I mean,
what we're doing right now,
the media,
the media works,
the publicity works,
that commercials work.
And if you look at the,
at the quadrupling amount of money that's been spent in judicial races in the
last 10 years,
you'll see that that's where that money is going there,
raising money in order to run more television advertisements and television
advertisements,
which used to never be used in judicial racist or only in the most rare cases
are now almost mandatory if you're going to seek and appellate,
uh,
position,
um,
on a state court.
So more money,
more television advertisement,
basically crowding out the messages that might be more salient about what is
important about a judge.
Um,
but,
but an a voter who wants to be informed,
who will dig around a little bit,
can get more meaningful information.
It's just that it's easier to get to absorb the information that's right there
in front of you on your television set on the 32nd and the 32nd answer,
often much more,
um,
uh,
interest provoking than a pamphlet that you get in the mail that tells you how
many cases judge Brown has decided in the last year.
And of course there are lots of,
uh,
issues and a lot of candidates on the ballot.
So judges are just one of maybe 20 or 30 people running the election,
right?
And not even in an,
not even in different kinds of elections,
but in some jurisdictions,
large cities.
For example,
um,
I come from Tennessee and in,
in 2014 in Shelby County,
you will be in judicial races alone.
You will be asked to vote on something like 70 candidates from the supreme court
all the way down to the lower court judges,
so like 70 different judicial offices alone,
and then add to that bow at all the other offices.
So it's it,
it really does take a vigilant citizenry who cares about their courts,
uh,
to,
to dig in and figure out who needs to be on the bed.
Sure.
One last thing.
With all the concern about money now in judicial elections about distortions in
the ads and good people getting voted off the bench and people may be being a
reluctant to be judges because of these things.
Uh,
do you see any prospect that,
uh,
electing judges will change in the near future in any places?
Well,
you know,
there are lots of heavy weight people working on that issue.
Um,
Justice Sandra Day O'connor,
many,
many former justices from state courts,
people all around the country working on the issue of reforming the way judges
are selected.
And fortunately we haven't seen a trend in any state toward um,
changing the selection system to either a merit selection or uh,
a long term appointment renewal system.
The what trends we have seen are in the other direction.
Um,
unfortunately I live in one of those states who has had a very,
uh,
very good merit based evaluation system for judges.
And now the ideal is to take it to a completely politically controlled system
where the governor will appoint and the legislature will confirm so that the,
the idea that the judiciary is a third separate and independent branch of the
government will basically be meaningless.
And there is a,
another state Kansas,
which is also considering that type of change.
So we have not,
we have not gotten any traction in getting states to change.
I have hope because I think that that for years,
the money issues and the,
the,
the large amount of money being spent in the negative campaigning with
centralized in about six to eight states and now it's spreading.
And I hope that as people see the results and ramifications of that kind of
money and the influence on air at courts and how it takes judges time,
attention from the bench
and reduces the caliber of people who serve on the bench.
That may be we'll wake up and,
and the trend will shift,
but I don't see that yet.
Well,
it's certainly an important issue in capital cases and all kinds of criminal
cases,
and we're very grateful,
uh,
professor wide for you to take time and to come from Tennessee and talk to us
about this and share the insights that you've had as a result of working on this
issue,
uh,
over the last 20 years.